foreign
let's go to Christian Sister Christian
in Kansas City Missouri what's up
hey Dr John how are you partying dude
what are you doing
uh not a whole lot it's Friday so
enjoying that Friday nice nice risk 28
degrees I think so that's fun risk 28
degrees if it got to be 28 degrees in
Tennessee they'd shut the state down so
what's up man
uh first I was gonna say thank you for
all all that you all do y'all are great
um really helps uh listen to you guys
I've extrapolated a lot
um and put into practice some of what
you teach and advise and it's made a
difference I appreciate it um thank you
thank you for listening dude in Our Gang
yeah and I also I know you're from Texas
but open invitation if you ever want
some real barbecue head on over to Casey
we'll hook you up all right fighting
words and I've had barbecue in Kansas
City and it is incredible I've got
family in Kansas I love it it's
incredible awesome um yes very well done
very well done
so I wanted to call and talk to you
about something I think I've kind of
combated most of my adult life
um it's a
the one one phrase I guess is the inner
critic but the more ominous title is
imposter syndrome okay so I
um what kind of brought it up was one of
your callers I listened to not too long
ago was a young gentleman that was
um you'd get burnt out really quick on a
job and switch to a new one every
several months or so and then after that
I was just like you know what I need I
need to call Dr John so
um I'm actually taking a new position
um at the start of the year
really excited about it
um but then here come all these feelings
of are they going to find out that I'm
not the right one do I know enough do am
I smart enough will I contribute enough
like all of these things that are
telling me that
I don't measure up okay
um and when I was starting to write some
of this stuff down to kind of keep my
thoughts in order I was like you know I
think I've dealt with this for a long
time it just manifests in different ways
um like one example would be when I was
going through undergrad
um when I would you know write all these
down and you know demand evidence from
them as you would say
um graduated with honors uh 3.8 you know
GPA so it did really well but the entire
time I was just like is this is this
major for me like am I smart enough to
do this for for my life you know is
um who taught you
that your thoughts about yourself didn't
count as much as somebody else's
um
just home
um so like in the about me stuff
um
I had a pretty strict upbringing I would
say
um I know my parents probably had the
best intentions sure but it was the way
I absorbed it and the way I have kind of
been brought up to think about myself
was you know minimizing pretty much
everything so so there's a pretty strict
Church oh so good I was gonna say
there's
um
there's some pretty compelling research
about strictness
and strictness void of relationship
creates very anxious uncertain kids
yeah because there's a message of
strictness if you will
um
that ultimately says you cannot be
trusted
and there's some truth to that you're a
child of course you can't be trusted
right but there's this it's the air you
breathe your thoughts are stupid what
you think you want to do is stupid the
things that you think are going to make
you feel good are stupid you want to be
in relationships stupid
and it's just this it's this it becomes
your heartbeat
there is some power to very strict
parents who also have very deep
relationships with their kids that's
what I'm aiming for I'm a strict dad
um like let's take video games I talk
about that a lot I'm very strict when it
comes to video games and
I also know that because I've said no
over here means I have to be very open
to doing things with my kids because
I've taken this option off the table for
them which means we've got to spend time
together which means you gotta kick a
soccer ball which means I have tons of
opportunity to tell my kids how that I'm
proud of them that they're doing good
work we laugh together they get to see
that they can make their old man laugh
right or they're faster than me or
whatever the thing is and so the
strictness is in combination with
relationship and that is the quadrant
I'm aiming for but if you grew up in a
home that was just you know why we don't
do this because we don't want to burn in
hell and you're dumb right I
not a conducive way to create an adult
who feels certain about anything right
yeah other than your own demise right oh
my gosh yeah so yeah that was yeah we
went to you know church every Wednesday
sometimes you know multiple times twice
on Sundays of course I was a norm uh dad
was in law enforcement so it was always
like it's like my same house and
behavior and perception were everywhere
not misbehave because then I look like I
can't control my kids or we get nasty
looks at church or all those things and
if he's in law enforcement it's you
can't misbehave because
if you hold hands with that girl that's
gonna lead you to dancing and if you
dance that's going to lead you to
smoking cigarettes and if you smoke
cigarettes You're a murderer right right
and that's that's what law I mean that's
the world right that's their world yeah
and so um everything's a gateway drug so
all I have to say is this
um
I want to back out and just teach on
this for a second is that cool I'm going
to use you as a proxy so okay your brain
is always scanning 24 7 365 asking and
again I'm I'm way oversimplifying this
but it's always asking am I safe
do I belong where is my tribe right so
am I safe here do I have a tribe to have
a gang and does this feel good the
opposite being
am I in pain right and it's scanning all
the time for these questions and if you
find yourself in a new environment
are they paying you more money by the
way
uh it'll be the same pay but
um like right now I'm working from home
and I think part of my issue is just
where I left I had a really great
relationship and I don't like I'm you
know pretty isolated
um just really hard to get any sort of
meaningful interaction so right this
place will have some some interaction
this will be like a hybrid thing so very
cool so so this idea of am I going to
belong here
and so your body's already spinning like
man I don't know about this and then the
safety what if they meet me and they
don't like me and if they don't like me
I'm gonna get fired if I get fired and
and I'm not like man this is a gift that
people who work in law enforcement give
their kids but it also turns into a
curse of an adult
you are trained as the child of somebody
in law enforcement
to think 17 steps down the road
and you very quickly I'm guessing can go
from
what if I don't know enough to I'm
homeless and destitute and my family's
fear catastrophizing is one of my
go-to's well hey it's because our dads
my dad's the same that guy loved me like
crazy and all day every day he dealt
with murder
and so he knew the steps to not get
murdered and that was right imposed on
like on as a kid and so man everything
was done out of love
and also it made for an insecure adult
like I don't know I don't know how to
walk I don't know what to do there's
murderers everywhere right and it's just
spinning so
um Claire Joseph has a couple of great
definitions of imposter syndrome one is
imposter syndrome is the gap between how
you currently see yourself as being and
who you think you need to be
and for your whole life somebody has
been telling you who you need to be
and instead of teaching you how to ask
yourself that question
okay that's number one number two is
imposter syndrome is the fear of others
judging you the same way you judge
yourself
and you are not nice to Christian are
you not at all because Christian sucks
and he's never doing it right and he's
always good come on come on Christian oh
now he's going to hell ah got it right
there's no way there's no way for
Christian to win
and so you spend a ton of time
thinking about Christian and how is
Christian going to keep safe and I won't
put you on the spot but I often see
folks who are
um world class I'll say this nicely I
won't say Liars but exaggerators
they're able to get in and out of social
situations or work situations
and they're able to navigate this and
navigate this because they've been
practicing it since they were a kid
they're very very skilled at it and then
all of a sudden they find themselves in
a professional position
and they have either said they could or
demonstrated or kind of around the edges
given the impression that you can do
this job cool you're hired and then it
goes oh no
yeah
right
you're talking to a guy that hired a an
accounting student
that to come into my office you sneak
into my office
and he taught me how to use Excel when I
was running multi-million dollar budgets
because I didn't know how
right I had to go get extra training
from a student who was paying me tuition
dollars so that I could do my job
right and so
[Music]
let me just say this ask you this are
you a fraud are you a fake
no you're not I know you're not no okay
so self-doubt is about what you know you
can do and can't do self-doubt is about
skills all right
if you don't have self-doubt you know
what you can do and you know what you
can't do imposterone imposter syndrome
is not about what you think you can or
can't do
it's about who you think you are
and that's a huge difference that you
don't belong that you're never going to
be enough that you're going to get fired
that you're going to screw this thing up
you're not going to fit in at this new
job what right it's a feeling in your
body that you don't belong in this job
or you don't belong in this room or you
don't belong in this marriage that's
imposter syndrome
okay and so I'll ask you so so solving
this problem let me say this solving
this problem isn't about
trying to get new skills
it might you might need to learn some
stuff in your job in fact I would hate
it for you if you took a new job and you
don't have anything to learn that would
be a lame existence hopefully you have
tons of new things to learn right yeah
yeah it'll be a plenty to learn for sure
yeah
going into a situation and not knowing
things is only bad when you've lied
about what you know if you've
misrepresented yourself if you haven't
done that then going into a situation
and not knowing what to do next is
called being a human
you've heard me on this show say I don't
know when somebody calls me with their
problem or I've been pretty open about a
number of times I call an expert like Dr
Lynn Jennings or Dr Michael Gomez or Dr
Lane Norton I called him and asked him
hey I'm getting this I'm having a call
today on the show I don't have any
experience with this walk me through
what uh what you would do because you're
an expert in this thing like that's just
that's being a normal human being
and so that comes down the cool thing is
getting over imposter syndrome is an
internal thing it's not an external
thing you see what I'm saying
so yeah go ahead so I've done a lot what
do you think that's okay no that makes
so much sense because like growing up
like I have like one of the phrases I
heard repeated a lot was you have so
much potential why aren't you doing X Y
or Z like why are you only getting a b
like why why aren't you doing this
homework like why aren't you whatever or
when I would even younger when I would
be upset or something I got uh I'll give
you something to cry about like there
was there was no physical abuse but
there was that threat that whatever
you're upset about is not worth what
you're like the energy or effort you're
putting I mean granted I was probably
young and I wanted the toys I couldn't
you know I couldn't have it or whatever
but you know growing up and that's all
you hear right so am I even so you just
you just nailed imposter syndrome
number one the the Finish Line always
moved on you
yeah hey dude I got all these in a b you
couldn't have got one more B one more a
really
yeah you know like seriously is that who
you are you're just all A's and a b kind
of guy
and so right so you go home and you have
this like I did it I got I got always
gonna be and then the finish line moves
and then you would have got straight A's
and it's like
one of these is at 90. you barely made
it
and then all right so the finish line
moves again and then at the same time
you're being told on repeat you cannot
trust your feelings bam I hit my head oh
that hurts no it didn't I'll give you
something to cry about right and it's
this it's this it's it's like
um it's like uh like an hourglass right
with the sand like just
slowly draining out of out of it
that's what happened to your ability to
trust yourself
and so what you have to practice moving
forward is how do I trust Christian
again no not again how do I trust
Christian period
and here's the way I've had to learn to
trust myself
I hold two things in in one in one hand
and one in the other
in my left hand I hold bad things could
happen I could get fired
I can get hit by a dump truck
and so I'm gonna make sure I've got life
insurance so my family's taken care of
and I'm going to make sure I'm really
good when I show up at work
I hold that very loosely
what I hold relatively tightly and the
other hand is it's probably not going to
happen
does that make sense so I give myself
Grace I make room for
maybe this isn't as big a deal as your
as your body's making it out to be maybe
it's not so let's don't respond to an
email for 24 hours
on the other side of it is hey my body's
telling me this is a huge deal it might
be
so in 24 hours I'm going to re-examine
this I'm just going to learn to trust
myself over time
and when my body starts to feel like I
don't belong in a room like I'm an
imposter like I'm fake like I'm ah
I just smile
and then I'm curious what are you trying
to protect me from
because I know this here's here's the
thing that happened we got I got a call
out of the blue I'm getting on an
airplane I got a call out of the blue
hey Jordan Peterson's team just reached
out to you
um would you would you be on his show
tomorrow morning in Los Angeles
um
I was like okay and then I thought oh
man that guy's real real real smart and
we don't agree on everything
and he is a controver he loves Contra
what if I end up getting dragged into
deep water and he's smarter than me and
we head off into the like he's a union
psychologist and I'm not in fact dude I
started going and then it ended up with
who do you think you've already be
sitting at this table
and then I started smiling and I was
like oh I know what you're protecting me
from embarrassment getting canceled
looking dumb right and then I worked
myself back dude I've worked in colleges
for years I've been with faculty members
who are brilliant and have wonderful
minds and interesting perspectives and
that's my so I was able to just demand
evidence from it and reverse engineer it
to I'm just gonna have a great
conversation and if I look dumb my wife
still likes me on most days my kids love
me right and I can go back to being a
high school basketball coach I love I
was good at that and so I was able to
land in a place where I could have a
good conversation and now they're that
particular episode's got millions and
millions of views because it was it
wasn't a and I found also Dr Peterson be
a lovely human being like off air he was
a great great guy so all that to say is
no matter how good you think you are
I've got two phds I've got all this
stuff I've got a number one bestselling
but my first thought was you don't
belong at that table who do you think
you are right it still happens and then
I'm just gonna work through my process
I'm gonna be curious about what my
body's trying to protect me from am I
safe do I belong here and does this feel
good I'm going to be Off to the Races is
that cool
yeah cool My Hope for you is you you
begin to trust yourself as much as your
employer trusts you
are you married
yep does your wife trust you
yep
no question are you worthy of her trust
do you lie to her a lot
no you cheat on her
nope okay
so
your wife who you love and Trust has
said I trust you
a a for-profit company who can only stay
open if they make money has picked you
as the best person to lead that
organization in that particular area
they hired you to help them serve people
so that they can make money to stay open
they picked you
so it sounds like the only person who
doesn't trust Christian in this equation
is Christian
and maybe Christian's family who again
loved you deeply in an effort to keep
you safe ended up robbing you of the
ability to walk on your own two feet and
so your life mission
for the next five years ten years is
learning to trust Christian learning to
trust your feelings learning when to
know when when your feelings are
Banana's out to lunch they're way off
um
learning when to make the next right
move
learning when hey this is something I
should really be scared about or uh it's
just my body being anxious again
you're going to practice those things
write them down write them down write
them down write them down
check in with your wife
chances are she's tired of Christian
talking to her husband the way you talk
to you
because she loves you but remember
self-doubt is about what you can and
can't do you don't have that
imposter syndrome is who do you think
you are to even be in this room
and my hope is over time with practice
and with intentionality
you can lean back and throw your
shoulders back and say I'm Christian
and I've earned the right to sit at this
table
your move man congratulations on your
new job you're gonna do awesome